you know
it's what we do
our Spidey senses are tingling as Toby
Maguire speaks on the future of his
version of Peter Parker and whether or
not we can expect to see him back in the
MCU sometime soon as we know back in
2021 Toby reprise his role in Spider-Man
no way home joining forces of Tom
Holland and Andrew Garfield's Peter
Parker's plural in order to pick the
spell that caused the Multiverse to open
up and allow visitors from alternative
realities to appear including all past
Spider-Man villains in a recent
interview with marvel.com Maguire
reveals that when they first approached
him to return to the franchise he simply
said finally adding I got the call was
immediately open about coming to do this
not without nerves you know but to get
to show up with beautiful talented
creative people and play it together
it's just like yes it's fun and exciting
you are amazing you are amazing thank
you when asked if Noe home with his
final curtain call or if fans can expect
to see McGuire suit up sometime soon he
revealed I love these films and I love
of all of the different series if these
guys called me and said would you show
up tonight to hang out and goof around
or would you show up to do this movie or
read a scene or do a Spider-Man thing it
would be a yes adding because why
wouldn't I want to do that while the
next installment of Spider-Man is still
in development the MCU is lining up film
after film with Avengers the Kang
Dynasty in the distant future so it begs
the question how and when will Toby's
potential return be because as we know
the great power comes
oh great responsibility I need
[Music]